bonjour jean françois clervoy bonjour
vous êtes ingénieur et astronaute
rattaché à l'agencé spatiale européenne
vous avez passé 675 heures dans l'espace
à bord de la navette d'abord atlantis
puis discovery pour trois missions 1
entre 1994 et 1999
vous êtes actuellement confinés dans
votre domicile dans les yvelines
oui c'est exact oui avec ma femme parce
que mon fils est tout seul dans son
appart dans paris est ma fille et en
australie le confinement finalement ça
doit pas être difficile pour vous c'est
quelque chose que vous avez déjà vécu
dans l'espace alors je véhicule
confinement dans l'espace mais c'est pas
le même il est pas tout à fait
comparable
ici on n'est pas isolés on peut appeler
nos proches on peut avoir de l'aide à
domicile si besoin est on peut sortir
nous dans l'espace on est confiné
parce que dehors le milieu est extrême
et invivable donc nous sommes dans un
confinement étanche est tout petit alors
ça varie avec la durée et le nombre
d'équipages de dire que dans ceux où
vous la capsule russe ces trois
personnes pendant deux jours maximum
dans l'équivalent d'1 5 mètre carré dans
la navette spatiale dans le cockpit
c'est l'équivalent d'un 10 à 12 mètres
carrés pour six à sept personnes pendant
quatre jours mais d'arrestations se
passe et internationales c'est
l'équivalent d'un 300 m² pour six
personnes pendant six mois d'envoyer le
confinement dépend beaucoup les
conditions de confinement du volume du
nombre de personnes et bien sûr de la
durée donc le confinement je n'ai connu
aussi un peu similaire a su qu'on lui
maintenant avant le vol tous les
astronautes sont en quarantaine pendant
une quinzaine de jours pour éviter
d'attraper une maladie au dernier moment
parfois ils sont en quarantaine après ça
arrivait rarement mais c'est arrivé pour
éviter de contaminer le public à
l'extérieur avec d éventuels microbes
ramené du milieu extra terreste c'est le
cas des missions apollo par exemple lors
quel état d'esprit on se trouve dans un
confinement dans l'espace mais aussi sur
terre pour la préparation de ses voyages
alors effectivement c'est une bonne
question la différence fondamentale
entre le campement que nous vivons tous
en ce moment est le nôtre dans l'espace
c'est que celui que nous avons dans
l'espace on y est préparé
on n'y pense même pas on sait qu'on a
besoin d'être protégé et notre
confinement pour nous c'est un abri
c'était une fonction protectrice
et on est obligé d'accepter pour la
mission qu'on a accepté et on y est
préparé
là il ya une grande majorité des gens
qui sont pas du tout préparés ils n'ont
jamais vécu le confinement à part celui
qui est randonneurs qui fait du camping
dans des milieux un peu extrême
il sait ce que c'est quand on est
confiné donc la règle de base comme
soient confinés dans l'espace ou chez
soi il faut savoir pourquoi pourquoi je
suis confiné
quand il ya un sens quand il ya un but
quand il ya une mission derrière on
l'acceptent parce que on veut remplir la
mission
après il faut être organisé organisée
dans l'espace parce que on peut parfois
pas facilement à sortir de chez soi pour
savoir quelles sont les ressources à
bord par exemple ne serait-ce que de
nourriture de pièces de rechange ou de
doughty s'il ya besoin de réparer les
choses et et après partager avec les
autres des ressources par exemple la
salle de bain par exemple à l'écran de
télé entre les enfants qui veulent voir
des dessins animés ou les ados qui
veulent de moi je jouais avec des jeux
vidéo donc être organisées dans l'espace
ranger parce que très rapidement cette
game bazar si on est ordonnée et puis
avoir un planning
nous on a un plan de vol voilà je vous
montre ici le plan de vol de mon
troisième vol spatial qui était un vol
destiné à réparer le télescope spatial
hubble
c'est un gros bouquin check list qui
décrit presque à la minute près qui fait
quoi quand et où
donc nous avons un but à atteindre nous
avons un confinement qui nous protège du
milieu extérieur et nous avons un plan
d'activité
c'est très important d'être de
s'astreindre à se donner un planning
si on attend que quelqu'un nous dise
quoi faire on peut facilement se
retrouver à devenir wazi que c'est
malsain et bien sûr le sport le sport
est prévue chaque jour merci jean
françois clervoy pour ce témoignage et
ses conseils bien je vous souhaite à
tous de bien vivre à travers ce
confinement en pensant toujours à la
mission pour qu'on sorte tous indemme en
très bonne santé